se nos pide restar menos 6x a la cuarta
menos 3x al cuadrado porque más 5 y a la
cuarta de 2x a la cuarta menos 8 x al
cuadrado y al cuadrado menos ya la
cuarta y bueno te invito a que pongas
pausa el vídeo a que lo intentes ahora
voy a suponer que ya lo hiciste que ya
lo intentaste ahora hagamos estos juntos
vamos a restar este polinomio verde de
dos variables de este polinomio rosa de
dos variables entonces puedo yo
reescribir esto como 2x a la cuarta
menos 8 x al cuadrado porque al cuadrado
menos y a la cuarta menos y esto lo
escribo en paréntesis tenemos menos
menos 6x a la cuarta menos 3 x al
cuadrado porque al cuadrado más 5 y a la
cuarta muy bien ahora
nota que estoy restando a este polinomio
verde de dos variables de este polinomio
rosa de dos variables y eso es
exactamente lo que se nos pide hacer
aquí así que aquí será igual esto voy a
reescribir lo que está en rosa tenemos
lo que está en rosa
tenemos 2x a la cuarta menos 8 x al
cuadrado porque al cuadrado menos llega
a la cuarta
y ahora voy a distribuir el signo
negativo entonces el negativo de menos
6x a la cuarta eso será igual a más 6x a
la cuarta
entonces pongo más 6x a la cuarta y
ahora el negativo de menos 3x al
cuadrado porque al cuadrado eso será 3x
al cuadrado porque al cuadrado positivo
y por último tenemos un signo negativo
que multiplica a 5 y a la cuarta
positivo entonces tenemos menos 5 y a la
cuarta así que estamos restando 5 y a la
cuarta y ahora podemos podemos intentar
simplificar esto primero veamos este
término tenemos 2x a la cuarta y
buscamos otro término que también tenga
el x a la cuarta y bueno aquí está
entonces a 2x a la cuarta le sumamos 6x
a la cuarta y eso a que es igual bueno
pues yo tengo dos veces algo y le voy a
agregar otros seis
eso será igual
a 8 x a la cuarta 2 + 6 es decir tengo
todos x a la cuarta más 6 x a la cuarta
eso es igual a 8 x a la cuarta y ahora
tenemos 8 x al cuadrado y al cuadrado y
vemos que le estamos restando estamos
restando 8 de ellos entonces bueno acá
estamos sumando 3 este término si lo ves
tenemos 3 x al cuadrado y al cuadrado
por lo tanto podemos sumar los
coeficientes vamos a quitar 8 pero sumar
3 ajá quitamos 8 y agregamos 3 lo
podemos ver como menos 8 x al cuadrado y
al cuadrado más 3 x al cuadrado y al
cuadrado cuanto es menos 8 + 3
eso es menos 5 así que tendremos menos 5
x al cuadrado y al cuadrado
acabamos de operar este término y no te
olvides del signo negativo que nos dice
que estamos restando 8x al cuadrado y al
cuadrado entonces lo ves como 8 x al
cuadrado y al cuadrado negativo más 3 x
al cuadrado y al cuadrado y por último
estas restando 1 y a la cuarta y está
restando otros 5 y a la cuarta cuanto es
eso menos 1 y a la cuarta menos 5 y a la
cuarta eso es menos uno menos cinco eso
es igual a menos seis así que nos queda
menos seis y a la cuarta y listo
terminamos restamos esto de esto